so i want to keep talking a little bit
about uh vaccination
and about republican senator rand paul
republican senator rand paul has always
been
sort of an odd guy not the person i'd go
to for
political philosophy or medical advice
or really anything um he has been
obsessed
with badgering dr anthony fauci and
other medical experts with conspiracy
theories
throughout the pandemic dr rand paul
yes is refusing to get vaccinated
against kovid
apparently for no better reason than he
wants to anger liberals
so what do we know about this so far
senator rand paul has now said on a
couple of different shows
he is not going to get a coronavirus
vaccine and
rand has said this multiple times he
said it during an interview with
john katzenmatitis on his radio show
on wabc 770 am
here is rand paul saying it on you know
who knows some other interview that he
did let's take a listen to it
have you received the vaccine yet now
that it's you know widely available to
anybody in the u.s do you plan to
yeah i had the disease naturally there's
about a hundred million americans who
have had it naturally
all the scientific evidence all of the
studies have shown that there is a
long-lasting immunity from having it
naturally
if people want to get vaccinated if
they're older it's not an unreasonable
thing
but i think for people in my age range
and younger who have had it
i think the vaccine is superfluous but
everybody can make their own decision on
it in a free country everybody gets to
so at this point yes i don't think
there's enough evidence leading me to
think that i need to be vaccinated since
i've already had the disease naturally
now unfortunately there is a lot at
least
probably wrong with what rand paul is
saying
it's important to mention a lot of the
things rand paul is claiming to know for
sure
are sort of open questions but we have
more and more information
that points actually the other way so
there are some extensive antibody tests
that have been done
and first and foremost it does appear
that the immunity you get from a vaccine
lasts longer than the immunity you get
from recovering from coronavirus
naturally many studies and papers have
found this
we're showing a screenshot of one of
them to our video audience
right now so in other words there's a
reason why
people are being told even if you've
recovered from the virus still go ahead
and get yourself vaccinated
uh because it appears as though you know
we we hear about people getting covered
twice
um it appears as though the immunity is
longer lasting
and more robust from the vaccine than
from just getting the virus and
recovering now
second again from what we know so far
and much of this is still being
studied but why take a chance it is less
likely it appears less likely that the
variant will get around vaccine-induced
immunity
than natural recovery immunity in other
words
the antibodies that you have from the
vaccine
are more likely to protect you from
varians and this means
all of the major variants of concern the
british variant
of course if you recovered from the
british variant you'll work
you're well protected against the
british variant but big picture
we have the british variant the
brazilian variant the south african
variant california
new york india and there's probably more
at this point in time
it appears as though if you got covered
and recovered naturally
you were less protected against the
variants than if you just just go
and get yourself vaccinated now this
could all be wrong
but that's where things are pointing
right now and so what rand paul is
saying very casually on multiple
interviews and radio and tv programs is
counter to the best medical science that
we have right now
it furthers vaccine skepticism it holds
down vaccination rates which we're
hoping for i mean listen people who want
to get out of this we're hoping for
vaccination rates to go up
and if people who are already more prone
to be vaccine skeptical because that's
what republicans are right now
if they hear rand paul say this and then
they act on that basis
it hurts all of us now the bottom line
is that
this is merely rand paul i'm talking
about
sort of right-wing populist type
libertarian-tinged
virtue signaling everyone should be free
to do whatever they want it's all framed
as being about liberty and being about
for the people sure i'm not going to
disagree with that but let's give them
real information
remember that tucker carlson on fox news
has been pushing a bunch of really
vaccine
skeptical stuff without saying whether
he
himself is vaccinated we did a segment a
few weeks ago sean hannity on his radio
show
refused to say whether he has been
vaccinated he actually
had some very strange rant where he said
you know i had researched stuff and the
johnson johnson vaccine was sort of the
one that was most interesting to me
but now that everybody's saying get
vaccinated did you get vaccinated
now i don't want to say because of
medical privacy and whatever now it has
nothing to do with hipaa medical privacy
means hipaa
people just casually asking each other
have you been vaccinated which vaccine
did you get that you have side effects
doesn't violate medical privacy doesn't
violate hipaa but sean hannity now
playing coy
something as simple as a historically
effective vaccine
that will save millions of people versus
just letting the virus run rampant
has now become a politicized issue it's
being couched by some of these
republicans
as an issue of liberty and of freedom
when it is really not what it is now for
people who like to say because i know
people will say this
rand paul is a doctor okay listen
rand paul is a medical doctor now some
people will email me some anti-vaxxy
this is so weird
anti-vaxx people will email me and
they'll say you know david
you should really highlight the work of
doctors
who are saying you should not get the
vaccine and then i look and it's okay
it's a phd it's like a doctor of
education
it's we're talking about medical doctors
rand paul
is a medical doctor that is true he has
training
as an ophthalmologist an eye doctor he
hasn't been board certified since 2011
and i love my ophthalmologist i've had
the same one for 30 years
i don't go to him for epidemiological
questions
i don't go to him for questions about
infectious disease
when there are so many experts in the
field including one we interviewed
yesterday dr isaac bogash from the
university of toronto and toronto
hospital
so for anybody who's going to email me
and say but
sir rand paul is a medical doctor
okay save the email i don't need it if
you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an ebook or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version
and read it i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video